Speaker 1: Donald Trump is now furious that
Ron DeSantis stole one of his lines.
But the truth is that Trump stole the line
from Reagan.
They're just stealing the same stuff from
each other back and forth.
Okay.
Talking Points Memo Article.
Trump attacked DeSantis for blatantly plagiarizing
a speech line that Trump actually took from
Reagan.
Trump actually took from Reagan.
The line is the great American comeback.
So team Trump published this video of Trump
using the line in 2020, and then DeSantis
using it now, meaning to prove that DeSantis
stole it from Trump.
Speaker 2: Three years ago, we launched the
Great American Comeback.
Right?
Tonight, I stand before you to share the incredible
results.
I'm Ron DeSantis, and I'm running for president
to lead our great American comeback.
Speaker 1: So this is like the perfect microcosm
of what I expect the 2024 Republican primary
to be.
Trump attacked DeSantis for stealing the phrase
great American comeback.
In reality, Trump took the term from Ronald
Reagan.
Trump didn't invent it, by the way.
He also didn't accomplish the great American
comeback.
But that's a different thing.
If you do a Lexis Nexis search for that term,
you have hundreds of pages of results.
Okay.
The phrase great American comeback has been
used in speeches for so long.
But you go back to Reagan's State of the Union
speech in I believe it's 86, and there it
was that in that particular speech, Reagan
bragged about 37 straight months of economic
growth and falling interest rates.
And he said it's because of conservative values.
And he talked about the great American comeback.
So Trump didn't invent it.
If you want to argue that anybody has a claim
to these phrases, it would be Reagan.
Also important.
Trump didn't make up Make America Great Again.
Reagan used a slightly different version of
it back in 1980 where he said, Let's make
America great again.
Let's make America great again.
So my view is these are not such unique phrases
that anybody really, really holds a right
or not.
Obviously, it's not a legal right, but even
sort of like a moral right to them.
These are very general phrases in many ways.
But to the extent that the idea is that these
are unique messages from Republican candidates,
they're not.
And Trump yelling at someone for stealing
something from him that he already stole from
someone else is pretty damn funny.
I expect this to be exactly the type of issue
that these Republicans argue about during
the during this campaign.
Now, one other just like kind of funny thing.
You might have noticed that in that ad.
Ron DeSantis pronounced his name DeSantis.
This is like a kind of funny thing.
Ron DeSantis, in older videos, used to pronounce
his last name DeSantis.
And then more recently, while he's been governor,
it's been dis Santos.
And then in that video, he went back to De
Santos, and it's all kind of weird.
Trump posted about this himself to his platform
Truth, social.
Speaker 2: Censure.
Speaker 1: Where he put Have you heard that,
Rob?
Do sanctimonious wants to change his name
again?
He's demanding that people call him DeSantis
rather than DeSantis.
Actually, I like Doug better, a nicer fellow.
So I'm happy he's changing it.
He gets very upset when people, including
reporters, don't pronounce it correctly.
Therefore, he shouldn't mind the sanctimonious.
This is going to be the dumbest, but possibly
the most corrosive Republican primary I will
have ever covered.
That's that's what I'm expecting and that's
what I'm preparing for.